bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale tv
actualité spécial chorus 2009 donc très
grand tournoi chorus 2009
nous recevons aujourd'hui pour commenter
ce tournoi jérôme blot fra prolonger
rome bonjour stéphane alors va te
présenter à ce qu'ils te connaissent pas
oui au niveau chicken avoir évidemment
puis on parlera après aussi d'autres
activités
donc tu es tu un joueur classé
internationale plus de 2100 urgent coin
j'ai atteint 2100 lots et puis je suis
un peu redescendue faut être
complètement honnête je n'ai petit peu
redescendue ces derniers temps mais bon
je sais c'est par manque de pratique
alors tu es prof d'histoire au départ
alors tu es aussi aujourd'hui très actif
dans le monde échiquéen puisqu'en fait
tuer alors tu vas me pose tout à fait
nouveau un peu un peu extra on va dire
donc tu es au sein de l'académie de
créteil
seulement on qui gère la seine saint
denis alors seine-saint-denis
val-de-marne seine-et-marne c'est à dire
environ entre 850 mille et un million
d'élèves et d'étudiants devant sion
contre les étudiants qui sont delà du
bac
alors et alors avec une mission
échiquéenne sait seulement que 36 est
pris alors seulement nouveau c'est la
volonté du recteur jean michel blanquer
air qui a lancé cette mission jeux de
l'esprit à 2 ans de 2 vouloir étoffer
son équipe puisqu'il avait nommé un
inspecteur d'académie à plein temps là
dessus et puis l'avenue donc étoffée et
il se trouve que mon nom avait circulé
et finalement j'ai été détaché donc en
septembre
8 pour un an peut-être renouvelables sur
cette mission qui consiste à développer
les échecs de la grande section de
maternelle jusqu'à la fac d'accord qu'il
s'agit bien ici de d'introduire dans
cette
dans cette académie peut-être avoir un
niveau de test alors soit quoi qu'on
peut considérer que le test avait déjà
été validée encore son nom mais à un
niveau test de développer le jeu
d'échecs comme outil pédagogique comme
support pédagogique pour peut-être pour
améliorer les résultats ou pour
développer des capacités chez les élèves
voilà il s'agit pas de former des
champions ça serait le rôle d'une
fédération
le l'académie de créteil a plutôt
vocation à utiliser les échecs comme un
outil dans plusieurs acceptions du terme
outil pédagogique pour aider par exemple
les élèves à mieux structurer l'espace
ou améliorer leurs capacités langagières
par exemple mais aussi pour résoudre
certains problèmes de comportement qui
existe partout et notamment dans cette
académie qui est un petit peu difficile
par endroits par exemple en seine saint
denis et on compte sur les échecs
notamment pour ici de cadrer les élèves
les horribles les aider à se concentrer
et donc à part valoriser leur potentiel
à prendre confiance en eux aussi
apprendre grâce à ses soutes à cet outil
finalement en quelque sorte à ce qu'on
sera mieux se concentrer aussi toute son
attention un sujet à mieux se concentrer
plus longtemps de façon plus efficace
structurée sa réflexion
donc s'il pourra le faire pour un
problème de mathématiques ou même pour
une rédaction en français donc de la
même façon que le sport je dirais
physique apprend à développer ses biceps
et vraiment raccord puissant l'idée
c'est d'aller décide d'aider l'esprit en
quelque sorte à améliorer sa
concentration et sa capacité de valin de
rester concentré sur un sujet et de
réfléchir un problème
complexe tout simplement voilà et en
prenant les échecs comme une sorte de
discipline carrefour qui serait au
croisement de toutes les toutes les
autres matières en quelque sorte
l'idée ce n'est pas de rajouter quelque
chose en plus c'est éventuellement de
traiter même des points du programme de
mathématiques ou de français ou même
d'anglais à travers les échecs
tout à fait alors donc ça c'est très
intéressant en ont l'occasion d'en
parler puisque tu es notre invité pour y
compris des deux prochaines émissions en
diagonale tv aura bien le plaisir de
reparler de ça alors on va parler aussi
de ton actualité pascal or non seulement
tu fais tout ça donc au joueur d'échecs
prof d'histoire a maintenant des tâches
et l'académie de créteil pour des pour
développer tout ça alors tu es aussi
auteur en fait donc des passionnés
d'écriture en parlement et et tu as tu
as tu sors une pièce un à paris qui
s'appelle donc période des transferts
alors peut-être on peut la montrer à
l'écran période des transferts lance
alors ça c'est une corde à son arc on ne
connaît qu'on ne connaissait pas moi non
plus donc c'est tout nouveau donc c'est
la comédie saint-michel à paris aussi
jusqu'à quand enfin alors c'est jusqu'au
2 mai ont jusqu'au 2 mai donc on a le
temps d'y aller c'est ces grands soirs
par semaine les jeudis vendredis et
samedis à 21h30
voilà donc ça alors c'est à la comédie
saint mich alors parlez nous de cette de
cette pièce alors c'est aux pièces
intérieures ne parle pas d'échec déjà
faut le dire clairement période des
transferts
ça fait clairement référence au foot la
période des transferts c'est la période
où les joueurs changent de club et il se
trouve que là les trois héros de la
pièce se retrouve chez l'un d'entre eux
pour regarder un match de foot à la télé
mais en réalité c'est aussi la période
des transferts dans leur vie puisque ils
font un premier bilan autour de la
trentaine il faut un premier bilan de
leur vie leurs femmes de leurs enfants
de leurs parents de leur boulot ils se
rendent compte de ce qu'ils ont réussi
ou pas réussi et du fait que justement
ils sont une période charnière de leur
vie et où ils vont devoir faire eux
aussi des choix c'est la période des
transferts
au signal pour le foot que pour eux dans
leur vie personnelle mais il devra
ruines futur peut-être changé de
direction et donc changer de club
voilà je souhaiterais vous me faire
rentrer des remplaçants alors on peut
voir à l'écran
voilà que par des transferts donc à la
2g remous fera à la comédie saint michel
à paris
vous pouvez réserver donc c'est le 01 55
42 92 97 voilà
donc
je parle soirs par semaine trois soirs
par semaine au 2 mai jusqu'au 2 mai
c'est une comédie c'est pas une comédie
où les portes claquent c'est une comédie
de donneurs ces convois trois garçons
sur la fiche donc et ça semble parler de
foot mais je rassure tout le monde
on peut y aller bien sûr un couple parce
que c'est aussi amusant pour les
demoiselles jeune femme de pouvoir
savoir ce que pensent les hommes ou de
quoi il discute quand ils sont tous
seuls gouvernements vont pouvoir faire
les petites souris alors maintenant on
va passer évidemment à notre à notre
parti du jour évidemment ce chorus 2009
alors de très haute facture on il ya
alors tous les joueurs les meilleurs
sont pas là puisque cramique est pas là
à n'en est pas là non topalov étoiles a
donc les trois bières sont pas là bon
faut savoir que topalov prépare un match
contre comme ce qui comme ce qui est là
mais on voit bien qu'ils y jouent pas
n'est en préparation voilà ils jouent
pas vraiment à son meilleur niveau parce
qu'il prépare son match contre topalov
alors des champions du monde il doit se
reposer il doit être bien content et de
profiter d'une un repos bien mérité
voilà de repos bien mérité et écrin
unique sans doute aussi puisqu'il est
bon il doit prendre un peu de recul
maintenant pour essayer de revenir
d'être d'essayer de reconquérir son
titre pourquoi pas même si ça va être
longue puisque puisque prochain match ça
il pourra pas jouer parce que ce sera
totale aux fucam ce qui donc qu'ils
rencontreront and under ont enfin bon
c'est comme ça
oui on va pas on va pas polémiquer en
espérant que ça se sache s'arrange dans
le temps alors on va voir aujourd'hui
une très très belle partie de l'autre
grande grande star maintenant des échecs
sans doute le nouveau bobby fischer des
échecs et on peut dire ça ce qui nous
rappelle vraiment bouficha par sa
jeunesse par sa fougue par sa part sa
volonté
avant de sortir des variantes
quelquefois picot le fait qu'il n'ait
pas d'un social vient pas de vision de
l'école soviétique ou donner quelques
échos elle que ce soit il s'est vraiment
l'impression qui s'est fait tout seul
aussi quasiment il sera pas dire qui
sort de nulle part il vient de norvège
qui est un grand pays qui nous a déjà
donné des champions mais c'est vrai
qu'il n'est pas aimé lui d'une académie
particulière c'est un joueur qui a une
certaine indépendance d'esprit aussi
dans sa façon de jouer
c'est safina un style tout à fait
particulier alors on va voir cette
supercar scène dans sa partie contre
radjabov donc qui est aussi un jeune un
jeune joueur donc personne doive en 18
ans diabo fait à peine plus serré c'est
entre guillemets le match des futures
voilà c'est peut-être mèche
une chose qu'on verra dans dix ans
exactement niveau peut-être championnat
du monde futur alors noah ça cette
partie entre carsen et radjabov au ce
tournoi de chorus vous allez voir une
très très belle partie qui montre bien
le style le style de carsen donc eu
quatre pour qu'arsène donc début début
ouvert et c'est 5 de la part des mois
donc ça c'est là c'est la sicilienne
c'est la défense sicilienne que vos
classiques intel fait classique les
noirs contrôle ici le centre avec un
pion de côté contre la casse des cas là
c'est le grand thème de la sicilienne
bien sûr c'est le contrôle de cette
caste des 4 et la possibilité pour les
blancs les noirs de faire des poussées
nécessaire pour libérer leur jeu sur
cette colonne câble f3 pour les blancs
aussi ce donc qui est une la vente
je crois paulsen je vois que ça
s'appelle enfin tout cas qui plus je
crois il faut jouer à 6 au film enfin
c'est une des variantes d'autres
possibilités que si c'est jouer soit
décider si ce pourquoi j'insiste que je
suis j'ai six tout de suite ou qui avait
laissé cissé plein beaucoup de coups
mais voilà c'est le jeu des noirs sur
l'a6 cn l'avantagé d'être assez flexible
et de pouvoir ans de pouvoir s'adapter
aussi en fonction du jeu des bleus alors
la typique de carsen dans cette danse
est parti c'est le coup numéro 3 alors
au g3 tout de suite
carson sort des grandes idées parce que
laurent fait là le coup le plus vite et
pour les blancs si le coût des quatre on
à ces occasions qu'on apprend voilà de
façon automatique on est toujours sur
l'a6 yens ou quatre cavaliers f3 et
ensuite des 4 et bien sûr pour essayer
de s'approprier ce centre qui est
important dans l'ouverture contestée au
noir leur volonté de s'approprier la
colonne des et se battre justement
contraception c'est qui est un petit peu
en huile a essayé voilà délibéré le jeu
parce que pour sa beauté vie dans ce
pion maintient un peu à la maison
soutien des quatre en général on trouve
tout de suite parce qu'il est blanc
contre aussi les noirs contrôle trop
vite trop bien cette cas ça va être
difficile après avec le cavalier c6 le
fou angers7
ça peut devenir assez compliqué pour les
blancs en signe de se développer de
façon harmonieuse alors donc g 3g 3g qui
est surprenant puisque j'ai un contre
joué trois avec les blancs la 6ieme
fermé par exemple on essaie plutôt de
jouer quatre donc de ne pas mettre le
câble f308 ici voilà bon ma façade joue
évidemment et donc arts scènes typiques
sort des sentiers battus le plus vite
possible c'est son credo il veut sortir
l'adversaire toujours deux des
préparations des grandes lignes connues
il veut l'emmener sur des terrains pas
forcément les meilleurs objectivement
parlant mais n'est plus le plus
peut-être les plus difficiles à traiter
voilà et puis les plus propices
peut-être à mettre son adversaire dans
une situation inattendue un petit peu à
la manière du champion du vin et du
début du 20e siècle emmanuel lascars qui
avait le premier dit qu'il fallait jouer
non pas tant une partie d'échecs dans
l'absolu qu'une partie d'échec contre
une personne particulière et adapté
éventuellement son style à la personne
qui était en face c'est très intéressant
la réponse sera diabo fait logique vu
que les blancs n'ont pas réagi au centre
tout de suite des cinq voies la normale
essayez de faire une réaction directe au
centre donc cesser
s'approprier cette colonne des renforcer
son contrôle sur le centre voilà tout à
fait logique et les noirs profit de ce
petit coup de côté comme ça montre pour
avoir des pur-sang trop fort alors
évidemment le fou en g2 après fera une
contre attaque sur ses centres et les
blancs ne perdent pas davantage dutreil
a pas de problème avec ça mais c'est une
réaction saine logique le coût des cinq
donc la carcel bombay a du mal
évidemment à ne pas échanger en d5
puisque une protection par cavalli c3
serait sans doute je regarde des quatre
qui viendrait du temps sur le cavalier
bon voire pourquoi pas un développement
de canal et m6 aussi donc je n'avais pas
de gros problèmes pour les noirs donc
prise en d5 avec l'idée suivante après
eux prendre des cinq de jouer tout de
suite le coup des caps maintenant pour
les blancs avec l'idée en fait pour les
pleins de désir bonne tôt ou tard je
vais changer ses 5 et les noirs vont
rester avec un pion isolé ce qu'on
appelle le piaui solution isolée
c'est toujours embêtant d'avoir toujours
pas toujours mais de manière générale
c'est embêtant d'avoir un pion isolé
pour la simple et bonne raison que il
peut pas être défendue par un autre pion
voilà ça signifie qu'il va y avoir il
faut nécessairement une pièce à la garde
de ce pion si ce n'est deux ou trois et
en finale il risque d'être plus faible
puisqu'il sera plus jamais lié au sov
échanges et passera plus jamais lié un
autre pion de l'autre côté évidemment il
ya toujours des accords de vente âgées
d'inconvénients l'inconvénient
effectivement quand tu mets le dire
c'est en finale et le fait de devoir
mobiliser des pièces à la défense de ce
pion l'avantagent c'est que les noirs
profite du coup de deux colonnes ouverte
la colonie et la colonne ces semi
ouverte qui pourra taper sur le couple
fiancé et la possibilité d'avoir des
avant-postes aussi pour leurs pièces
célia notamment les cavaliers sur la
case éventuellement ces quatre voire
voir venir ce sont des principes
généraux le purise au venetian forcément
une faiblesse voilà le radjabov peut
profiter de l'ouverture des colonnes à
condition d'être le plus rapide à se
développer
voilà mais le problème c'est que là les
noirs donc bon alors on voit la suite
donc avalé ces six de la part des noirs
d'oncologie consorts la pièce en plus
ont une petite pression supplémentaire
sur des cadres dont car ça n'a pas de
problème puisque le cavalier 3 protège
des katja pas qu'il n'y ait pas de souci
on fout g2 carsen maintenant continue
son développement évidemment il veut
croquer à ces visuels éviter les visites
peut pas perdre de temps et la fouge et
quatre de la part de radjabov alors ça
c'est intéressant fuji 4 puisque les
noirs cloud le cavalier 3 qui peut pas
bouger et donc font une pression
indirecte son pion des cadres venant des
quatre est potentiellement un prix le
problème c'est que s'ils prennent quand
un champion
ils vont quand même resté le roi au
centre et c'est peut-être pas l'heure de
faire ça on voit ce que fait car scène
très logiquement mais pas évident
forcément pour reprendre débutants mais
regardez il fait même pas attention aux
pions il pourrait choisir de prendre et
si prononcé cinq permettrait aux fous
ces 8 2 sortira mais gain de temps vous
faut et fluide pardon de sortir des
gains de temps on prend on perd on peut
en apprendre et hop les noirs en profite
pour se développer
donc là les noirs gagner un temps de
développement avec un pion isolé certes
mais du coup des colonnes aussi à jouer
donc un jour peut-être facile à
développer
donc petit rock de carsen donc là tout
de suite comme ça pose un souci parce
que les noirs pourrait envisager
maintenant regarder puisque le cavaliere
3 et cloud est vrai que de faire le coup
cavaliers prend des cadres donc c'est un
vrai sacrifice en fait que propose cap
seine
puisqu'il aura des morts pourrait
effectivement propre prendre ce pion
alors le carême le cas mettra pas de
problème puisqu'il est bien protégé
jahjaga le fou la dame contre deux
pièces on peut rajouter qu'avec des de
la défense non mais on a besoin de moins
alors au tournoi marc pourquoi qu'est ce
qui justifie cette décision c'est la
volonté encore une fois de d'ouvrir
rapidement les colonnes une colonne
ouverte d'un quart la scène décide d'en
profiter
donc pour ça il faut qu'il mette un sort
à l'abri et deux qu'il active sa tour
c'est ce que permet de faire le rock
puisque maintenant la tour peut se
rendre en intra rapidement et exercer
une pression assez forte sur un roi noir
qui n'est pas prêt de roke puisque là
encore le cavalier en danger mythe et le
fou en fuite voilà alors là ici car
scène en plus donc aurait une solution
pour enlever les problèmes c'est
l'isolément des mains avec échec au roi
il faut parer les chèques et donc le
câble f3 n'est plus flou et donc menaces
après de prendre les quatre avec un
doublement de pions en général demain
deux pions permet de prendre le premier
plan facilement et le deuxième va être
très faibles après là et là comment
défendre si les noirs joué le coup car
il ya aussi ce pour éviter essayer de
garder le ton de plus et bien les blancs
pourraient en profiter par exemple
toujours tout simplement carlier ou 5
avec un cavalier au centre attaque le
fuji 4 on va le fou le fou g2 qui
commence à taper sur des cinq même pensé
à jouer c4 après pour exercer une très
forte pression sur sur v cette voie là
parce que c'est 4 après si on prend un
c4 évidemment le fou peut venir prendre
en bessette et et on peut même envisager
car les chinois qui débloque une pièce
et après la sortie du fou très vite le
tour vient de faire une pression
terrible donc sur l avantage de
développement énorme de la part des
blancs pour le pion donc ne pas hésitez
toujours pareil cette histoire de gambie
a donné des pions pour du pur du temps
mais il en fallait voir ce petit coup de
main et ce qui fait que radjabov et un
choisi de ne pas prendre parce qu'il a
un peu peur de cette initiative il a
raison sans doute donc il joue le plus
tranquille fuoh cette voie la fossette
coûts de développement logique il
ensuite joué de kabylie et 6 et rouquet
phocéenne regarder pourquoi fawcett
puisqu'il couvre les chèques de
déjà donc là maintenant il menace
vraiment de prendre sur n'aura plus ce
qu ailleurs juste un défaut c'est que si
les blancs prennent deux des quatre ans
et 5
le fou va devoir reprendre c'est ce que
fait d'ailleurs car c'est ce qu'incarne
scène d'ailleurs maintenant que la
menace est là bas il dit oui même toi je
peux prendre je prends et ça oblige le
fou est à rejouer qui finalement aura
joué deux fois
voilà donc les blancs n'ont pas perdu de
temps en prenant des cinq puisque les
foules et noir auront joué deux fois la
foudre frappe très important de compter
les tempos donc ça c'est bien
hélas les blancs donc ont réussi à
garder un pur isolé pour les noirs s'ils
nord développe vite ça peut ça peut du
coup bon mais ne pas être un vrai
problème à cause de la colonne se mue en
une guerre ouverte c'est des postes en
avant c'est quand même du recentrage
aussi pour l'un c'est un pion central
donc à la cage de gaz notamment qui est
intéressante on vous prend c'est simple
hélas quand même l'idée de car ce n est
toujours là d'un jeu en échec chez
courant et
les noirs doivent trouver une réponse
l'idée c'est qu'on des clous le cavalier
f3 alors les noirs auraient pu jouer il
ya plusieurs coups pour défendre c'est
ce coup donc revenir avec le fousseret
était quand même sans doute pas une idée
le coup le plus logique serait sans
doute de sortir le cavalier pour par
l'échec préparant le petit rock mais là
les blancs en fait avec un contrecoup
puissance et le ku'damm c3 avec mon
problème puisque on attaque à la fois le
fou c5 et c7 le pion g7 vous voyez c'est
pas si simple de pas rester cheikh
autres coups possibles pour les noirs
c'est de jouer le ku'damm set mais dans
ce cas là le problème c'est évidemment
le pion des scènes les plus protégés et
on pourrait gagner du temps par le coq a
laissé trois pour attaquer la casse des
5 et pourquoi pas la dame derrière
sachant que calais ces trois sur dame
prend dames avec l'idée de changer
d'armé on joue cavalier g7 ça marche pas
puisqu'il ya ton revin échec échec et
même sur claudio 7 on peut prendre des
cinq puisque le quatrième set est cloué
par au prince oui ça va vite
développement est très rapide
et puis même on peut avoir une dette
jouer aussi ici dame c3 on peut aussi
jouer jusqu'à sa menace un tourin très
ennuyeux pour eux une menace ou toi avec
un clown la dame est l attaque toujours
les pions jessel on attaque le cube et
cette mêlée noire pourrait revenir avec
le footsie sans doute mais il ya pour
jouer cavalier m6 se développer ici
et en cas de toux rejouer faut aussi ce
même si c'est un peu effectivement
passif cpc c'est une autre idée possible
tout à fait le ku'damm 6 3 voilà donc
tout ça fait que finalement berradja bof
c'est pas si simple pour lui de trouver
la réponse en vie normale un autre coup
kung fu au cices permettrait d idées
comme classiques comme cavalier cinq
attaques le foot tout simplement avec la
dame derrière donc sacré des vrais
problèmes et toujours dame c3 qui est
possible attaquantes où toutes les
pièces donc c'est pas simple pour à
diabo fait donc radjabov on joue
finalement on se résout un jour il faut
7 donc ça fait trois coups pour le foot
rend toi qui joues
d'infos sur sur neuf coups 3 3 plus même
fois là ça fait beaucoup ça fait
beaucoup et il n'y a pas trop le choix
en fait pour l'instant mais bon il n'y a
pas pour l'instant de gros avantages
blanc puisque on a un deux trois coups
de développement pour les blancs si on
considère que la dame aurait développé
même ciel bleu qu'en poule à tour quatre
coups avec le roi un deux trois pièces
sorties par des noirs bon ça va quoi
c'est pas y'a pas de perrine n'y a pas
encore trop péril en la demeure mais bon
il faut quand même faire très très
attention
alors qu'arsène mais n'en profite vu
qu'il a déployé son cavalier pour jouer
qu'avec 5 avec l'idée simple c'est
câblée cinq attaques lequel gad on gagne
un temps des clous en même temps le
cavalier ou valve fout pas évident
maintenant on sait pas trop ce qui fait
un g4 est simple si les noirs problème
le câble et cécile affaiblissent encore
leurs ailes dames il ya moins de pièces
présentes
et puis si on doit me prendre la dame
attaque encore g7 décidément se plonger
7 fm depuis le pion des cinq se retrouve
sous le feu nourri
non seulement de la dame mais aussi du
fou j'ai deux exactement sur ce coup là
évidemment il ya un gros problème parce
qu'on attaque à la fois j'essaie dé 5
avec la dame une foule le seul coup qui
permet de parer ça tranquillement ses
qualifs 6 pour parer les deux et ensuite
on peut imaginer tour un plumage in
eto'o qui empêche de roquet tout de
suite on ne peut pas invoquer puisque
c'est à minorer d'en prendre celle qui
est un vrai problème donc voilà donc
c'est pas simple c'est pas simple
cabello 5 reprendre tout de suite n'est
pas une bonne idée donc gbagbo se dit
j'ai un problème mon foot comme son
épouse hills et la personne il en a
réussi son coup parce que le foot et 4
il a perdu du temps à revenir
le fou au set il a joué un deux trois
fois maintenant il ya un très beau fou
dessin ou g2 qui tapent sur des 5
une dame qui est placé en faisant
pression quand même derrière soi sont
les noirs comptent toujours pas
développer leurs cavaliers g8 ni rockets
donc c'est le moment d'engager
les opérations quelque sorte et tout de
suite car cette boum
voilà encore une fois il ya une logique
derrière ce coup tout à l'heure on a vu
qu'ils voulaient profiter des colonnes
ouverte voilà il se dit on n'y a pas que
les colonnes dans la vie aussi les
diagonales
si les deux non plus j'ai 2 qui est très
très bien pour l'instant il peut être
encore meilleures voies utilisées ces
six civis bessette
je vise à 8 aussi il faut avoir de
l'ambition mais même on peut le voir
tout de suite parce que si les noirs
prennent en c4 comme tu dit jérôme et
vise à huit c'est à dire qu'ici
cavalières et cavaliers qui ont rang et
regarder tout simplement prend échec
échec et la torre derrière donc sap erp
sap erp une qualité est sans doute la
partie à ce niveau là la qualité ça va
vite
donc voilà donc déjà gros gros problème
pour les noirs ont pression terrible sur
des 5 on peut pas vraiment prendre si on
prend 1,5
ça résout rien c'est pire parce qu'on
fait dans prend il ya toujours des cinq
ans prise et en plus j'ai sept
maintenant tout de suite
donc vraiment c'est ça pose les vrais
problèmes donc la razzia boeuf et doit
se résoudre à jouer un coup de
développement et de lâcher un peu cette
fête ne pas tenir compte de cette
pression ici et de continuer à se
développer si ce qui est sans doute le
meilleur coup cavalière six mois ça
c'est bien
j'enlève toutes les menaces potentielles
sur g7 qu'on a vu je prépare tout de
suite le rock et je rajoute une
protection sur des 5
c'est le seul coup envisageable en
exactement problème problème tout de
suite c'est karl et ces trois cas les c3
très fort ces trois très fort parce que
maintenant la pression augmente sur des
ça fait quand même trois à
l'environnement pour l'instant ses
protégés mais regardez qu'est ce qui se
passe si les noirs rock par exemple tout
de suite mais tout simplement on peut
prendre des cinq éliminés si l'union des
5 et par exemple sur regardez par
exemple son cavalier prendre des cinq
tout simplement fait cavaler prend des 5
vous prendrez 5-fu prend dans prend et
regarder le problème donnant il ya la
dame ici face aux foules il suffit donc
de faire cavaler processus et s'affaire
une pièce absolument donc déjà c'est un
gros problème donc vous voyez déjà tout
de suite alors une autre possibilité
pour les noirs après petit rock puis on
prend des 5 c'est de dire que je prends
d'abord le cavalier ou 5
d'accord mais là on peut choisir de
prendre non pas de reprendre le cavalier
mais de prendre le fou et du coup on va
affaiblir le roi puisse comprendre à le
pion qui aurait 7 et le pion bessette
c'est maintenant et youtube étaient dans
la mire du fou j'ai 2 voilà donc fondé
joué le coup comme cavale et 6,6 et là
en plus les biens sont obligés de
prendre tout de suite puisque la dame
protège peu de continuer leur
développement par swift 4 par exemple la
tour va venir les gains de temps on va
affaiblir le roi noir et puis on a gagné
tout simplement pions dont al avance de
développement de carlson se perpétuent
ces salles à la force puisque l'homme
est un grand joueur c'est de pouvoir
maintenir cette initiative il a de la
vence dans le développement et crée des
menaces et il continue en perpétuer
chaque coup de créer une nouvelle
dynamique
pas facile donc socke a blessé trois
quarts scène se résout à protéger son
cavalier ces six tours s'est vite et ils
enlèvent la tour 2 justement de la
menace du fou absolument voilà donc un
coût relativement tranquille de la part
de rajab off qui essaie de tenir la
position mais là c'est leur regard des
rares disent que le jouet carsen c'est
tout à fait extraordinaire c'est très
joli
puis on prend des cinq ans ça y est
c'est là on y va tout de suite lors dé
son idée derrière la tête ont assez
extraordinaire vous allez voir c'est
vraiment très beau c'est pour ça qu'on a
choisi cette partie donc les noirs
prennent un dessin il va falloir normal
oui tout tient tout à l'air de tenir
sauf que fou à chis alors ça c'est
énorme
très joli coup de car c'est dans un peu
inattendu c'est rare de voir quelqu'un
un grand maître de ce niveau les pauses
et sophos sur une case mais pour le riz
comme ça alors pourquoi les grands
sacrifices assez étonnant il faut
comprendre pourquoi les gens peuvent se
permettre de venir garbia pas de menace
de ce côté là c'est pas ça l'idée en
devenant à chis évidemment ils menacent
de prendre g7 est en fait il peut se
permettre de faire ça parce que
lecavalier des cinq ici et vis-à-vis de
la dame et l'idée c'est de ramener la
tour en d1 pour clouer ce cavalier des
cinq dont on voit qu'il est attaqué par
le cavaly c3 par le fou g2 bientôt par
une toux ici les noirs ne peuvent pas le
défendre plus que deux fois
touré fou parce que si lecavalier 6
vient en b 4 pour protéger il suffira de
le chasser par l'aspect enchâssée dans
la crypte le mans 1-3 le chassera et en
laissant le problème au centre et donc
ils peuvent se permettre les blancs de
jouer vous aussi ce qui a l'air de
perdre une pièce ne perd pas à cause de
ce clou âge voilà il se croit jeu
permettra de récupérer la pièce avec un
pourquoi parce que on aura cassé la
structure des pions non seulement les
noirs peuvent pas décemment rock et de
ce côté là avec les dames encore sur
l'échiquier
voilà et puis et puis on a une structure
pourriture de pions pour très affaibli
pour une finale ça pose des pieux en
double et sur la colonne âge ça fait pas
plaisir très faible à la limite on
préfère les avoir au centre ainsi à
jouer oui
choisir c'est mieux
ça m'est alors donc ça me ferait des
pions très faible a attaqué plus tard
donc là on peut dire que là après ce
couac 6/4 scène a trouvé une
merveilleuse idée pour gagner davantage
il a pris davantage
c'est la troisième fois qu'il ouvre une
colonne d'une diagonale dans la partie
en l'espace de quatorze coups c'est
quand même il fallait voir fréquents
fallait voir ce coup là comme s'était
fallait le voir c'est pas évident 3 que
c'est mort fille au 19e siècle qui
disait emparez vous décollez ouvertes à
non seulement lui il est prêt à
s'emparer des commandes ouvertes non
plus il les prêts les fabricants tels
n'existe pas au prix d'un fou qui nous
aurons pris d'un fou apparemment c'est
un pseudo sacrifices il va pas perdre ce
fou puisqu'il va récupérer le cavalier
en d5 a minima donc la razzia bofa pas
trop le choix il faut qu'ils commencent
à essayer d'échanger parce que la
pression est trop forte à tous les
niveaux donc il essaie de d'échanger des
pièces et il prend le cavalier en scène
alors là car ça ne se presse pas il a
soudain prend au sein qui se prendrait
sans doute un peu confus et si ce qui
consolide g7 et qui attaque la dame
ensuite il promet dans ces 3 et grosso
modo s'en sortir et donc il faut très
vite que carsen maintenant réagissent il
a quand même pris part d'une pièce ici
il va sans doute perdre l'âme et les
noirs ont cette pièce ici qu'ils ont
prises et surtout enjoint tour des 1
voilà qui met sa menace à exécution
voilà où le cavalier des cinq sur la
dame exactement on va pouvoir s'assurer
de récupérer la pièce qu'il a investi il
n'a pas peur de pions propres ce qui a
pris d'apprendre cavaliers évidemment
lequel des cinq restera en prison à
cause du clown avec la tourache suite en
prise avec la torah schmid
bon alors c'est ce qui se passe quand
même car celle trouve sans doute le coup
un des coups les moins pénibles il va
prendre quand même le fou et c'est pas
celle déjà pour lui bien évidemment il
peut pas prendre ces trois puisqu'il ya
ton prendra mais celle ci il bougeait
lecavalier
par exemple on g6 ce cavalier est en
prise tout simplement
mais on peut prendre un peu on peut
prendre le d5 par exemple du fou en
menaçant de prendre aussi c'est la dame
est en prison oui là c'est ça devient
catastrophique ça devient catastrophique
donc il faut il faut que les noirs
essayer de prendre le maximum de pièces
c'est toujours un peu comme ça quand on
a la pression et d'essayer après de s'en
sortir au mieux et de récupérer de pas
perdre trop derrière quand il va rendre
les bras devant les radios à devoir
rendre donc il faut qu'ils en prennent
pour pouvoir
voilà donc il prend tout prendre tout ce
qui peut prendre et a pris deux pièces
mais dans son sein qui fait dans les
réserves pour l'hiver et il les rendra
plus tard donc là car ce n a réussi son
coup les cas ces structures évidemment
il faut qu'il reprenne les pièces qu'il
a perdue donc d'abord d'en prendre 5 1
avec l'idée déjà rajoute une pression
sur des scènes qui surtout j'attaque la
tour je suis car radio peut pas se
permettre de faire ça un simple petit
rock parce que la pièce serait récupérée
par les blancs avec l'avantagé d'une
structure complètement cassé des noirs
il y aurait sûrement une attaque très
rapide sur le roc sur l'europe ne doit
essayer autre chose ils jouent faux ici
alors fois ci c'est l'idée j'empêche la
poésie nato j'attaque la dame dont je
gagne du temps toujours l'histoire du
tempo donc là car ça n'a pas le choix il
faut se bouger la dame avant de
continuer les opérations
donc il vient en e2 malin car scène ils
restent sur la colonne évidemment
puisque le fou aussi ses clous et ce
qu'avait dessin est foutu de toute façon
puisque il ya une pression terrible et
là l'idée des noirs on la voit tout de
suite c'est faut penser 3 voilà
maintenant que fo a été jouée au prince
et 3 pourquoi mais maintenant j'en
enlève un attaquant de la case et ça et
je vais essayer de tenir ma pièce de
plus malgré de gros désavantage que j'ai
là car scène a vu encore plus loin il
fait d'abord fou prend des 5
il n'y a pas de problème
puisque en fait ici il ya aussi pour les
blancs une double menace ils ont
toujours une pièce de moi mais une
double menace c'est de prendre le fou c3
et l'autre menace de prendre aux six
avec la tour c qui attaquera la nanon
comble et noir ne pourront pas reprendre
le foot donc les blancs restent avec
double menace très important les blancs
avaient donc dès le début de cette
combinaison
c'est ça qu'il faut bien comprendre en
fait sacrifier une pièce mais du mans
qui garde tout le temps dans la
combinaison une double menace il est
impossible de la récupérer mais il
fallait fallait pas se tromper dans le
londres et la haye après si on met
souvent des fois on lance des
combinaisons comme ça puis on oublie ce
qui se passe parce que ya trop de choses
ya trois choses donc là radjabov vous un
joli coup pour essayer de toujours
pareil d'enlever cette pression terrible
tentation les épaules dams est donc ça
c'est bien alors l'idée d'un 27
j'en enlève ici de la prise de celle de
cette tour en espérant nous les blancs
prennent en c3 et parce que là je prends
en d5 forçant les changes de dames et
d'alléger la position ça doit permettre
d'équilibrer la position en tout cas en
enlevant la dame de des mythes
effectivement il se retire de la
pression de la tour et puis des clous
fou aussi ce qu'il a dans les plu cloué
sur le roi qu'il supprime et de clouage
d'un coup ça a l'air d'être vraiment un
cookie qui tient la position mais la
carène a vu encore plus loin d'avoir
déjà ils continuent d'arriver c'est
maintenant échec au roi donc toujours
profiter du fait que ce roi et ostende
échec au roi
et là c'est pas c'est déjà assez
compliqué très compliqué voilà déjà ça
pose problème alors que font que fond
noir parce que là c'est pas simple car
il ya toujours la pièce de plus
évidemment
imaginons que les noirs jouent le coup
fou 17 17
bon l'idée c'est que j'ai une pièce de
plus donc si la dame bouge simplement
jorand lève mon fou et j'ai une pièce de
plus le principe pas évident récupérer
et blanc aimerait bien jouer tour f1
pour chloé la dame sur le roi alors il
faut protéger
voilà le fou ici en fait à un double
malgré que soient entreprises qui
contrôlent la case ou un qui serait en
bien pour les blancs puisque toi évident
franck loigerot nabeul en fait les
blancs ici peuvent se permettre beaucoup
d'attentes très curieusement le coût
d'un premier set c'est parce qu'elle
était loin de la partie mais il fallait
quand même réfléchir à cette possibilité
fo 17 qu'attaquer la dame d'un premier
set allait avec l'idée c'est que tout
simplement le fou ces trois étant prises
et alors la dame aussi en plus contrôler
les deux limites c'est pas très grave
mais et puis on va venir aussi sur la
case sur la case ou en faisant un
clouage donc loi jeu d'un cran donc ça
peut être aussi très embêtant et là les
noirs doivent réagir à cette menace de
reperdre leur fou ce qu'ils en c3 oui
parce que là la benâte avant tout en
devant maintenir le contrôle de la case
e toile athènes oui pourquoi et noir
d'autres doivent rentrer dans les
complications parce que si les noirs
faisait petit rock
si c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre qu'il
faut mieux comprendre les blancs
simplement faisant des princes et rois
ont l'avantagé du fait de la structure
complètement cachée du roi noir en plus
dans une menace directe c'est ici c'est
de faire des choses comme kung fu prend
f7 ce genre de trucs pour libérer la
tour sur la sur la sueur sur le fou 17
comment on pourrait prendre pour
l'instant des places mais on a aussi la
prise de façon sûre le pion à 7 donc les
blancs pas de problème au niveau des
pions si les noirs prennent ces trois
ils prennent à 7
il ya une structure en plus qu'assez ici
donc ce serait un gros avantage blanc
pour pas se permettre les noirs de jouer
simple il faut continuer à garder cette
pièce de plus le maximum de temps pour
essayer d'équilibrer les chances là les
noirs jour et un coup comme fou à 5
c'est quasiment c'est le seul coup parce
que si les noirs jouent un kung fu des
quatre ans pour dire mais font des
quatre est possible aussi puisque ici la
dame protège le fou donc la dame 17 ne
peut pas le prendre mais un coup comment
regarder tout simplement tour des quatre
et j'ai une double menace le fou est
aussi devenir maintenant 24 avec
pression par exemple imaginons kung fu
des six ici dans cette position tout
simplement tours 4 tous âges ici force
même coup comme par exemple ou cinq ans
et permettent même de jouer avec 4 même
si l échec de ces 5
on n'a pas peur les chais puisqu'il
restera cloué à j-6 surtout ce genre de
choses donc le le fou est perdu et si on
joue à notre cou comme un fou de 6 bat
tout simplement regarder ce qu'on peut
faire ici ce qui est très jolie
classique un insolent de position tout
reprend aussi ce pourquoi on n'a pas
peur de pions prends parce que la tour c
8 est plus protégé absolue on a éliminé
le défenseur et donc on va ramasser tout
ou pognon laisse mon magasin tout
magasin comédie ya plus rien magasins
comme dit l'autre donc voyez ce genre de
position donc
les noirs seraient obligées de jeu le
fou à 5 ans fait face m et là on jouait
le coupé quatre énormes avec la même
idée c'est que si on les noirs prénom de
b4 on a le même problème
si on prend de la dame par exemple
regarder si on prenait dames on peut
permettre avait les barres de fer fou
prend f7 pourquoi parce que après roy
prend avait tout simplement tour d un
prendre fou 17 avec le roi totalement en
l'air et une position en maths rapide
oui il ya maintenant quelques coups on a
une pièce regardez-la ici il y aurait
tout reprend 17 11 7 a besoin de
calculer regarder le roi n'a plus les
moyens de se défendre a aucune pièce qui
est capable de défendre le roi contre la
batterie ici par exemple a pris 3 g 6 eh
bien il se passerait par exemple coup
comme damas six échecs avec devenir en
d3 par exemple food et 6 quand même pour
parer les chèques et dans ce cas là on
vient en d3 et le roi n'a pas de
solution après roi m6 damev trois échecs
et les noirs par exemple venait en
premier sur la case
ici on le ferait d'un échec du cygne va
j'ai cinq tours ichec g4 et 2005 matt
est donc ici ça va très vite à mon
intérêt très vite là le roi est
complètement désemparé ya beau y avoir
beaucoup de pièces noires encore sur
l'échiquier les deux tours la dengue le
fou aucune peut se peut paraît vraiment
les et les échecs les colonnes et les
diagonales étant ouverte c'est facile
pour damer tour d'aller d'aller enfermé
petit à petit le roi noir et puis le
metn a tout simplement
exactement alors qu'est ce qui se passe
sur coup franc mais 4,2 si la même idée
qu'on a signalé convient de signaler
l'autre coup le coup simple reçoivent
comprend et sait être comme on vient de
le voir aussi parce que c'est
intéressant sur d'emprunt on peut
prendre le pouls beckham c'est
impossible d'empêcher le rock mais aussi
le simple voilà le symptôme des quatre
tout simplement aussi est là toujours
pareil la même menace
combien de voir mais ça n'a rien changé
puisque sauf que il ya plus de tomber
mais
comme on l'a vu ça ça gagne sagan tout
le magasin
donc voilà c'est un vrai problème pour
pour à diabo of food et 7 perd donc il
lui reste le coup alors ils en ciblent
droit les blancs peuvent simplement
prendre ces trois le roi et au centre
avec une attaque qui continue et donc en
guerre ne résout pas les problèmes qu'il
a la tourache 8 aura du mal à s'activer
les pions de la deûle et le roi reste
faible et on voit pas bien comment il
pourra à terme résisté à l'attaqué à
l'attack tout à fait donc dalle 17 il
faut que radjabov essayer de garder le
maximum de pression et puis c'est
d'échanger un maximum de matériel pour
que la finale soit la plus douce
possible parce que là il est un gros
problème de structure donc hélas alors
la carcel fait une erreur sans doute
dans le b 3 alors ça c'est sans doute
une erreur
c'est sans doute pas le meilleur en fait
il aurait dû choisir car c'est ni si
c'est l'axé c'est là que c'est un peu
dommage pour la pour la fin de cette
partie mais c'est bien d'enlever trois
bons qui quand même un bon coup c'est
pas un mauvais coup mais c'est pas le
meilleur parce qu'il aurait dû échanger
les dames cela hésiter 100 m sans doute
car scène à ce niveau-là échanger les
dames d'apprendre des sept échecs
pourquoi parce qu'après bon après trois
premiers sets ça serait pas une bonne
idée parce qu'on pourrait faire [ __ ]
prendre 17 récupère qualité verte oui et
à la fin on récupère le foot est roi
donc il faudrait faire fou prend tout
simplement et là à prendre comprend fou
qu on and on rééquilibre quand même on
reprend l'investissement de départ
moi je sauf que maintenant on est dans
une position où la structure à l'unrwa
est toujours faible et on a un pion b
cette emprise par le fou des cinq est
aussi toujours cette idée de
combinaisons fou prend ex est exactement
apprend tout reprend 17 derrière avec
l'échec est prise du pion b et
éventuellement du pion avec une finale
qui techniquement
casino gagne par exemple sur petit rock
un coup que me fou prend bessette et la
tour viendrait ans et 7 et après fou des
cinq tours princes et rois
les blancs ont une finale supérieure
avec des pions faible ici le roi aque
donc affaibli c'est pas trop grave il ya
plus les dames justement mais cette
position est favorable très favorable en
alors la position que je choisis car
sienne aussi sauf que là on a un
matériel qui est toujours fou contre
tours ou est-ce que après dame b 3-2
carsen on va voir ce qui se passe pour
ses 5
donc bon coup de radjabov qui pose la
question aux fous fous des 5
il profite du fait que le fou est
toujours à ses trois donc contrôler eux
il n'y a pas de problème de harcèlement
depuis lundi six versements il ya une
retournement de situation en quelque
sorte parce que maintenant le fou dessin
qui est cloué dans la mesure va sortir
voilà parce que là le faut aussi se voit
aussi ça peut prendre la dame embêté
voilà donc il faut prendre aussi c'est
ça s'arrange les noirs parce qu'après
d'en prendre six comme il va falloir
reprendre ces trois les dames
s'échangent et la carcel nord tente
encore de se compliquer de compliquer la
partie alors évidemment s'il avait fait
tout simplement d'en prendre six puis on
prend 1,6 et après il faut prendre le
font maintenant c'est l'heure après et
après tout reprend 6,3 ben il en tournoi
car sinon on va se permettre de faire ça
c'est pas c'est pas très favorable c'est
un peu dommage de entre guillemets
d'avoir gâché la tacc pour se retrouver
à qui on tombe dans ma 3 permet de
maintenir la pression la tour c
s'inquiète attaque et simplement les
noirs le protège le fou maintenant
n'attend plus que de sortir donc il faut
le prendre et après petit rock c'est la
même position un peu que tout à l'heure
sauf que au lieu d'avoir un matériel
tout fou contre tours fou on a un
matériel avec que des pièces lourdes
or on sait que toutes les finales de
tours sont nuls même quand on actionne
plus là c'est très souvent le
professionnel de tours et voilà et
effectivement quand on a un problème ici
de structures quand vous aurons un
problème de structure groupe au nouveau
partie d'échecs où vous aurez même un
pion de moins si vous arrivez à
transposer dans une finale deux tours
vous serez souvent très souvent la
possibilité de faire nul c'est
extrêmement difficile à gagner
il ya mieux vaut mieux se débarrasser
les pièces légères voilà mais se
débarrasser des pièces légères et garder
les tours qui pose le problème pour
valoriser ne tourne plus très souvent
dans sa conception passé éloigné soutenu
par la tour enfin tout un travail mais
là c'est pas le cas du tout il ya une
équivalence stratégique puisque on a
deux pions contrôle de vol elle est ici
trois pions contre 3 même s'il est blanc
arrive à gagner le pion doublé trois
pions contrôle de avec des pièces
lourdes ça fait nul sauf s'il ya un fou
c'est pas pareil non et donc voilà notre
différence c'est qu'on a des dames à la
place des fous ça ajoute au caractère
annulant de la partie si je puis dire
parce que on peut imaginer des
situations la dame va pouvoir donner un
échec perpétuel un moment bien ce
journal il ya moins de pièces sur
l'échiquier les dames peuvent justement
trouver facilement des échecs même dans
une position inférieure qui permettront
d' annuler radjabov ne veut pas espérer
gagner cette partie sauf erreur mais il
a peut-être réussir il a peut-être
réussi à sauver sa peau voilà peut-être
réussi à sauver sa peau en tout cas il
ya de vraies chances de nous ici on va
voir le fhaine la partie quand même
d'enfants assiette de carson qui en
profitent pour prendre plus recette il
vaut mieux parce que ici on a quand même
deux pions liée contre deux pions qui
sont isolés ici donc échanger pion à ces
deux constructions ces trois c'est une
bonne opération pour les blancs les lots
toujours davantage la structure est pas
bon ici mais on va voir que c'est quasi
impossible d'en profiter car ce n va ici
évidemment quand même c'est lui qui peut
jouer pour le guen touré fin et on va
voir le site bon il ya pas grand chose a
commenté sur les sur la suite il ya une
valorisation ici de l'activité des
pièces on essaie d'actifs de placer ses
pièces au mieux un petit échec pour m
leroy sur le sur les loyers du centre
puisqu'il comme on approche de la finale
à terme on peut imaginer que les rois
vont essayer de se diriger vers le
centre mais avaient les pièces pour
démonter les noirs n'avons pas échangé
pièce tourne à aucun moment ils vont en
garder au moins une tour à chaque fois
qui permet d'assurer la nuit
sont reprises aux échanges on le voit
bien ici moi ya des changes la ici les
pièces lourdes empêche toute progression
c'est très difficile de progresser alors
il ya quand même des chances de retour
ici qu'il faut que tu peux être forcée
ça se fait pas voyez c'est très
difficile de passer on peut continuer un
peu leur vie d'avant car c'est un essai
je suis un blocus et le 500d cas si
lourde au sens propre du terme échanges
ici des dames voyez c'est alors échangé
pions b6 contre le pion à voilà ici on a
l'impression classique trois pions
contre 3 ici même après la prise du
curiste trois pions contre 2 c'est
quasiment impossible à gagner ça les
grands maîtres le savent il n'y a pas de
problème avec ça c'est qu'on n'y arrive
pas c'est à dire que la position
classique final il faut savoir c'est que
tour pions contre roye tour ne gagne pas
donc si le roi et facettes en chasse des
pions et là en l'occurrence c'est le cas
il est en face des pions dont même le
pion passé qui peut avoir lieu ne
permettra pas de gagner c'est une
position théorique alors qu'arsène a
quand même essayé encore un peu voilà
mais ici ils ont très vite convenu après
une tentative d'avancée
donc même car ces loyers ils avancent
mais en plus il ya une pression ici et
ici sur ps3 il s'est échangé une pièce
mais même avec une tour voilà il arrive
à la nul ici après tout reste ruiz et
combien du nul les blancs ne peuvent pas
vraiment progressé avec une tour faut le
savoir
au final ça fait ça fait toujours une
bonne une partie du donc si une très
belle partie
combien de mois c'est une très belle
partie bas notamment l'ouverture on a vu
que 15 seine à issy est de dynamiser
tout de suite le jeu il a tiré parti de
tout ce qui était possible nous a fait
feu de tout bois il a ouvert l'école ni
la ouvrir les diagonales
il a peut-être commis une imprécision
effectivement au moment où il revient en
b3 avec sa dame là donc on va remontrer
cette position peut être un c'est un peu
dommage parce qu'effectivement il
pouvait sortir de cette attaque
voilà ici sur cette juste un peu ici sur
cette position sans doute l'erreur de
carcelle ici de ne pas accepter les
changes de dames
jusqu'ici c'était parfaitement joué avec
une vraie pression ce qui va récupérer
le foot est roi il aura un fou qui sera
très fort la colonne ouverte
la structure de pions noirs allaient
droit qui sera faible et puis pas le
même matériel y aura le même matériel y
aura du fou du roi du fou et après dame
prend 17
ici on oblige à reprendre du fou ce qui
permet de garder le fou qui peut faire
la différence
après si on prend ces trois que font les
frais quand il ya une menace de taureaux
en échec sur un petit rock on a le pion
17 qui tombe on peut même décider de
jouer ces quatre pour protéger il est
noir mais n'ont pas de possibilité même
tour c'est cette regardez qu'est ce qui
se passe autour de cette méthode en
échec
on ne peut pas protéger dès que six on
est obligé de jouer un coup comme
combrailles fuite maintenant simplement
tour ces trois et on a un avantage
toujours de structure claire un fou des
5 et centralisée des pions l'a doublé et
là il ya un fou qui échangent la
connotation de la finale on est plus en
finale le ps kurd le fou les fous
peuvent plus facilement aider au gain de
la partie
dans cette configuration à cette
configuration voilà donc très belle
partie car c'est une leçon d'ouverture
je pourrais y compris dans la surprise
et c'est donc même le voyez des nuls qui
peuvent qu il est bon c'est une île qui
aurait pu se transformer en gains
absolus
bon c'est bien de faire du guerrier
radjabov qu'a pris sa chance au bon
moment et laisser passer l'orage pour
être ça de cette façon un peu triviale
il l'a attendu que carlson commettre
sans précision et
cette chance bien des îles à celui-là
créer exactement car c'est numéro quatre
mondial ou 3 mondial à 18 ans donc qu'on
attend sans doute en finale de
championnat du monde d'ici d'ici
quelques années
ça sera sans doute le match à suivre
maintenant qu'on a eu lundi un champion
du monde
pourquoi pas un norvégien pourquoi pas
ça ce serait une première historique
déjà annoncé une première historique oui
c'est une première historique
ce qu'on peut dire aussi de carl scène
c'est que son jeu d'attaqué vous êtes
toujours ébloui depuis qu'il a 11 12 ans
il est dans l'est dans les colonnes de
toutes les toutes les revues des chèques
pour ces attaques fulgurantes là encore
il a montré ses capacités d'attaqué est
ce qui lui manque peut-être pour passer
ce palier vers le titre mondial c'est la
précision
c'est là le les coûts qui paraissent les
plus simples et qui sont quelquefois les
plus compliqués c'est à dire là de jouer
le coup de dames qui lui permet de
rentrer dans une finale gagnante
tout à fait mais merci jérôme et puis
donc on vous rappelle période des
transferts
je sais pas si on peut le montrer une
dernière fois à la merci à la régie et
puis je te dis bien des rares bientôt
jérôme et puis et puis à la comédie
saint michel pour voir ta superbe pièce
dont on espère que ça sera un vrai
succès envoie jusqu'à aussi merci
beaucoup
non pas au revoir à tous on va